OK, let's dig into this.
Bob Woodward holding the tapes for too long
discussion.
That's happening earlier in the show.
I told you about the audio taped revelations
that were released yesterday by journalist
Bob Woodward.
This is sort of part of his new book release
Rage, where he cites a lot of these recorded
conversations in the book.
He also has released many of those audiotapes
and they are shocking.
Donald Trump knew in February that the Corona
virus was far more dangerous than he's ever
really admitted.
But he was certainly downplaying it during
February, publicly saying we've got five cases,
we've got 15.
It will soon be zero, while privately, as
he said to Bob Woodward on February 7th and
around that time.
This is very serious.
Trump at the time thought it was airborne.
Trump thought it was hitting more than just
people who were older or sicker.
It is outrageous.
People died as a result of how Donald Trump
handled this publicly.
Many people, there's no question about it.
Bob Woodward's investigative reporting continues
to break news.
He's had an incredible career, no question
about that.
But the question that is being asked is, if
Bob Woodward had gone public with that information
months ago instead of now to sell a book.
Could lives have been saved?
In other words, knowing in March that Donald
Trump was still publicly downplaying the virus
and knowing that in February, privately, he
had acknowledged how dangerous it was.
Should Bob Woodward have said, hey, I've got
to release these audiotapes now because it
could save lives?
And indeed, there is a ton of blowback against
Bob Woodward now arguing exactly that, that
he should have blown the whistle and he should
have said, listen.
Trump is saying something publicly.
I have him on tape saying something very different.
Privately, some examples.
John Stanton, the former Washington bureau
chief for BuzzFeed, tweeted, quote, There
is no ethical or moral defense of.
Woodward's decision to not publish these tapes
as soon as they were made, if there was any
chance it could save a single life, he was
obligated to do so.
Bob Woodward put making money over his moral
and professional duty.
Jessica Kuzman, a reporter for ProPublica,
tweeted similarly, quote, How differently
might Trump supporters have acted if this
whole time they knew that he knew Cauvin was
a serious threat?
Woodward could have made that happen in February,
whosay Antonio Vargas, a filmmaker and former
reporter for The Washington Post, tweeted,
quote, If journalism is a public trust, a
trust that has consistently eroded.
And Bob Woodward is an associate editor at
The Washington Post.
Why did Woodward sit on this information while
Americans suffered and died?
Now, Bob Woodward was asked about that exact
decision in a brief interview he did with
the Associated Press.
And Bob Woodward's reaction was he needed
time to ensure that Donald Trump's remarks
were accurate.
Now, that sounds weird to me.
It's weird to me that for months, Bob Woodward
needed to confirm that Corona virus really
was deadly.
As Donald Trump told him, it was on February
7th.
That's weird.
But what would be a better counter argument?
There are few.
Let's examine them.
David Maraniss, who's an investigative journalist
and an associate editor at The Washington
Post, tweeted, quote, I agree completely.
And I'm puzzled by some of the short sighted
thinking on this by people with whom I often
agree.
The argument that lives might have been saved
had Bob reported this earlier is a historical.
The tapes are un invaluable public service.
Another argument.
This is Erik Wemple, a Washington Post media
critic, who said, quote, If Trump thought
Woodward.
I'm sorry.
No, this is not part of the post.
Erik Wemple makes the argument that, quote,
seeing a lot of arguments that Bob Woodward
did something unethical or untoward in holding
onto his scoop about Trump's admission that
he played down the coronavirus.
I disagree with the criticism.
Woodward is a book author, and the implicit
understanding with his sources is that he'll
interview them, interview them again and again
and again until he can stitch together something
authoritative in book form.
So where do I come down on this?
I believe that the strongest counter argument
is that it is very plausible that Donald Trump
never would have been interviewed by Bob Woodward.
In other words, he never would have accepted
sitting down with Bob Woodward if he had known
that Bob Woodward was going to publish some
of this stuff right away.
I think that that's a realistic thing if Bob
Woodward says, I want to interview you, but
I might just publish the stuff next week.
Trump probably refuses the interview.
The pretext of accepting the interview likely
included the belief that this would not be
published until it came out in a book months
later.
Now, Bob Woodward could have made the decision,
even though my intent was not to publish this
stuff right away.
This is of such public health importance.
This is of such national importance that I
have to go public with this.
That's something that Bob Woodward could have
done.
The question then becomes, would it actually
have saved lives?
I don't know that it would have.
Now, let me walk you through my thinking.
It seems obvious if Donald Trump had publicly
taken the virus seriously starting in February,
rather than denying its seriousness, a lot
of his followers would have taken it more
seriously and thus fewer people would have
died.
That, I think, is true.
The problem is what we're talking about is
not Trump publicly taking it more seriously.
What we're talking about is in March, for
example, Bob Woodward blowing the whistle
and saying, hey, Trump's lying.
I have him on tape.
I caught him red handed.
I don't believe that would have made a difference
to Trump's followers.
And why don't I believe that?
Because it hasn't made a difference so far.
Trump has gotten caught red handed, doing
everything you can imagine.
And his supporters, by and large, have not
punished him.
Nothing happens.
Now, we'll see in just over seven weeks whether
in total, Trump is held accountable for this
disastrous four years.
But I have a hard time imagining that even
if Bob Woodward did go public in March with
this saying, whoa, whoa, whoa, hold on a second,
stop the clock.
I have audio.
Trump knows this is serious.
Trump would come out and just insult everybody.
Magnani would have come out and done a press
briefing and come up with some rationale for
why this is not a big deal.
And then people would have moved on to the
next scandal, sort of how we are now moving
on to this one from dead soldiers or suckers
and losers from just a few days ago.
So if I were Bob Woodward, me personally,
I would have come forward because I would
want to clear my own conscience.
That's me.
Do I think it would have made a substantive
difference?
I have a hard time thinking it would have
because it.
Would be just like when any journalist comes
out with anything about Donald Trump, his
followers either don't believe it or ignore
it or write it off or whatever.
So if it were me, I would have come come public
because of my own conscience.
I don't know that it really would have made
a difference.
We're going to explore this in more detail
on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
I hope you were following us there at David
Pakman show.
We're going to take a quick break.
And next, I am going to dove into some new
policy proposals from Joe Biden.
We will look at a very strange interview that
Donald Trump gave to Sean Hannity
last night.
And so much more The David Pakman Show David
Pakman dot.com.